I want to ask you about something that a  lot of people noticed last year American  Idol  yeah the finals Scott McCready wins it's  a big deal you are present I was there  and it's this very emotional moment and  he goes out and you're right there and  yeah like everyone was getting hugs  everyone was getting hugs and you went  to hug him I went for the power hug and  I was you were dissed yeah yeah it was I  can't believe you're bringing this up it  was a shocking and painful moment for  all of America and I think we should  relive it  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  it's amazing how something like that  things go to your head you win the  American Idol he won he's totally filled  with power and forget about your best  friend he could tell that you had never  been in the Oak Ridge Boys like this  other guy